effective tomorrow morning the entire
government will be shut down until
further
notice You're a mean one Mr
grin hi there what's going on here puppy
puppy is here can we keep him my
neighbor's dog had a literally looking
for people to adopt I love him I wish he
had tiny puppy shoes I would totally
shine his little shoes for free a I do
say the cutest stuff look I love a good
dog as much as the next guy but this
building doesn't allow animals Andy take
them outside and shoot him no just keep
him outside oh come on Ron I'm just a
little puppy I ain't done nothing wrong
I'm just a
puppy I like her mustache I wish I could
have one but I can't cuz I'm just a
little
puppy okay take him out and shoot him
so who broke
it I'm not mad I just just want to
know I did I broke no no you didn't Tom
don't look at me look at Ben what I
didn't break it huh that's weird how'd
you even know it was broken because it's
sitting right in front of us and it's
broken suspicious no it's not if it
matters probably not but April was the
last one to use liar I don't even drink
that crap oh really then what were you
doing by the coffee cart earlier I used
the wooden stirs to push back my
cuticles everyone knows thater okay
let's not fight I broke it let me pay
for it Ron no who broke
it Ron Don has been awfully quiet really
yeah
really I broke it it burned my hand so I
punched
it I predict 10 minutes from now they'll
be at each other's throats with war pain
on their faces and a pig head on a
stick good it was getting a little
chummy around here well I'm sorry to
burst your cabubble but I just had my
ask handed to me by the city manager and
now this entire department is C
screwed Ron I'm so so so sorry what the
were you thinking I would prefer that
she asked me for my permission so I can
say no I like saying
no it lowers their
enthusiasm Ron Swanson
how are you present I have a meeting at
Public Works and I was thinking that
maybe you might want to sit in why would
you think that they are working on a
number of fascinating big budget
projects I'm very busy here that I am
being forced to brutally cut entirely I
can make room in my schedule wonderful
as you know I'm not a big fan of
delivering bad news Chris it would be my
absolute pleasure have you considered
cutting the entire fire department I
have personally put out several local
Fires at at no cost to the taxpayer
thank you John for coming in the public
works department is wonderful and you
are the best idea man in the business
also we're cancelling all of your
ongoing projects what what about the pon
River Dam Dam's dead have a nice day
where will all the water go wherever
it's headed now the important thing is
the dam is never happening and your
dream has been
crushed we're very sorry I am not good
meeting I want to thank you for being so
ruthless and cruel in a meeting the
other day you'll have to be more
specific with the public works
department about the dam ah what do you
say I take you to lunch and then we can
talk about all the projects that you
want to get accomplished that won't be
necessary I don't have any projects I
hate
[Music]
projects what a b we should order and
then we can talk shop what are you going
to have I'm thinking something raw in
cucumber
based a cucumber I didn't do anything
for my office it's okay I took care of
it I made a marshmallow Ron
Swanson gosh his arms are crossed
because he's mad at all the other
marshmallow workers for annoying him you
like
it it's
fine I can handcraft 17t canoes out of
Western red cedar but I can't glue two
damn gram crackers together look it's
really easy I know a lot about candy I
play with it I eat it sometimes I play
with it and eat it
boom okay new plan everyone else makes
this candy house and I make myself
useful
elsewhere turns out I cannot make a
gingerbread house which would bother me
if I were an 8-year-old girl everyone in
the universe loves a gross medical Story
boom I win
and so when I finally cleaned up the
vomit I found the toe I forgot about the
toe so did we crazy right that story is
awesome indeed thank you for sharing
Jenny Ann was getting a little chummy
when people get too chummy with me I
like to call them by the wrong name to
let them know I don't really care about
them that's a Genus move thank you
you're welcome
Lester we got one more gift for you it's
quarteron zebra wood joined by floating
tenons to the black walnut Corner posts
finished with a wiping varnish that's a
secret Swanson Family Recipe handmade at
my wood shop and you are correct it is
gorgeous well um thank
you um this tiar um caused by the
overwhelming thoughtfulness of my
friends will be my baby's first
memory salt water will warp the wood so
keep your tears in your eyes where they
belong we'll do Ron swansson and you're
kind and you're thoughtful and you're
always such a delight to have around I
am sure you are going to be an
incredible mother thanks Larry that's
nice goodbye
an I have enjoyed parts of our time
together oh God
Ron
that was really
something there must be a way out of
here I don't think there is they
installed these magnetic locks two years
ago there's no way around them yes there
is I'll simply punch my fist through a
window Ron there's security wire in
there you'll slice your arm open I would
rather bleed out than sit here and talk
about my feelings for 10 hours okay well
I'm not very good at visiting people in
hospitals so I'm going to go hey if you
see Andy will you not tell him I'm here
okay because of what happened I don't
want him to think stop don't want to
know the less I know about other
people's Affairs the happier I am I'm
not interested in caring about people I
once worked with a guy for 3 years and
never learned his name best friend I
ever
had we still never talk sometimes Diane
suggested we tag along to London for a
honeymoon I agreed because my love for
her trumps my hatred for Europe then she
hit a phase of morning sickness that
knocked her for a loop and decided to
stay home but she insisted I go and take
pictures for her the nodding Hill bus
tour starts at 2 The Love Actually bus
tour starts at 2:30 and oh the Bridget
Jones bus tour starts at 2:30 also what
do we do Ron your
pick look a clock we don't have that in
America you you call that a
tower try the Sears Tower friend Ron I
propose a challenge to see whose
motivational methods are more effective
challenge accepted I don't want to seem
overd dramatic but this is literally a
battle for April soul I don't want to
seem over dramatic but I don't really
care what happens here speaking of bad
reviews computers are mostly pointless
but that Yelp thing gave me a great idea
on how to criticize people in places
I am composing strongly worded letters
about things I disapprove of and I am
using the internet to get addresses
where I can send them so far I've
written to a vegetable farm several
European ambassadors a manufacturer of
male cologne and a non-fat Frozen Yogurt
Bar dear frozen yogurt you are the
celery of desserts be ice cream or be
nothing zero
Stars how much postage does it it take
to send a letter to Canada who's it
going to Canada it says dear Canada you
Ron please do it for me make the speech
Ron please please give the speech Ron
yes please Ron please please give the
speech please give the speech yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes please please
please please please please please
please yes yes all right damn it
woman okay everyone shut up and look at
me welcome div visions of nature
this room has several paintings in it
some are big some are small people did
them and they are here now I believe
that after this is over they'll be hung
in government buildings why the
government is involved in an art show is
beyond me I also think it's pointless
for a human to paint scenes of nature
when they could just go outside and
stand in it anyway please do not
misinterpret the fact that I am talking
right now as genuine interest in art and
attempt to discuss it with me further
end of
speech oh I forgot to sing you in my
Merry congrat your Christmas Carol
jingle bells jingle yay jingle good for
you get
out